along a roughly 25 mile stretch of shore
there have been more than 60 shark
attacks since records began and almost
half of them fatal
in fact this small area accounts for
almost 50% of recorded attacks in the
entire continent as a result its earned
a killing designation as South America's
deadliest coastline
[Music]
you can see for the shock attack problem
he's very serious it's probably one of
the most dangerous cities in the world
for having a swim residents are at their
wit's end I wouldn't know why it happens
here and always here
in an attempt to prevent further attacks
authorities banned surfing in certain
areas and signs line the beaches warning
of the dangers of entering the ocean but
the only real way to stop this bloody
barrage is to figure out how it started
it's absolutely crucial to find the
cause of the problem because if we don't
we can't build a solution so what's
driving this terrifying onslaught along
recife Shores and could other coastal
resorts be next according to former
instructor Fernando Clark something
makes diving in this area unique and it
hides deep beneath the waves Pacific is
the shipwreck kept off
Raziel the area around the attack zone
is home to dozens of sunken vessels some
dating as far back as the 16th century
but according to Clarke these ill-fated
ships are more than just rusty relics
the shipwrecks become a reef completely
full of marine life fish crustaceans and
molluscs call these down vessels home
but it's what these marine inhabitants
attract that could be problematic for
people when you go shipwrecked I've in
here most of the time we see a lot of
sharks the presence of sharks near
shipwrecks is a phenomenon that can be
seen elsewhere too in the u.s. sunken
vessels along the shores of Oregon
Florida and North Carolina are inhabited
by these predators the Sharks are on
track for the shipwreck because of the
food so could the wrecks of recife be
responsible for luring dangerous
predators near shore where people are
the Clark says the answer comes down to
the species of shark he sees most often
on his dives to demonstrate he plunges
into the shark-infested waters
before long he spots just what he's
looking for nurse sharks nurse sharks
are bottom dwellers attracted to the
crustaceans inhabiting Recife sunken
ships measuring up to nine feet they
possess powerful jaws with serrated
teeth and worldwide they have been
implicated in multiple attacks on humans
so could nurse sharks be responsible for
a CC spike doctor Fabio Hassan is one of
the lead investigators trying to get to
the bottom of what's happening along
this coast and when he analyzes the
details of each incident he comes to an
important conclusion nobody in Recife
has ever reported being attacked by the
North Shore
so the shipwrecks are not at all to
blame for the attacks instead Passons
analysis points to two other suspects
both of which have reputations for
attacking humans
the first one is tiger sharks tiger
sharks can grow up to 18 feet in length
and weigh in at 1,400 pounds known for
their undiscerning palates they're
equipped with sharp serrated teeth that
allow them to rip through seabirds
turtles and even people perhaps even
more imposing is the other culprit Hasan
implicates in this fight and that is
bull sharks
bull sharks bite with the most force
pound-for-pound of any large shark they
are fast and aggressive
and they're often found in the same
shallow coastal waters as humans
so it appears Tigers and bulls may be
responsible for the spike the question
is why
[Music]